all right so we'll start with Alexander
here who's going to be talking about
teaching data science in adverse
circumstances uh it's a little awkward
but well this is Plan B apologies um so
um adverse circumstances and this was an
example uh
[Applause]
of um so I live in Argentina that is the
um another part of the adverse
circumstance it's a nice country at the
very south of South
America um middle-income country uh we
have a rather High poverty rate and we
have inflation at
113% um so think about that the next
time you complain about six that you you
have here where it could be considerably
worse and everything is relative as we
all know the um I live in the capital
city uh buenos
Iris and I'm going to put hold this down
a little it's home to about a third of
the population rather concentrated and I
work at a public university there called
UNAM San Martin which a public
university in Argentina means that the
students uh don't don't pay any fees um
so it's
completely um subsidized by um Finance
by by the government or the
state so um during Co we actually
surveyed the students here and we found
that more than half of them do not have
access to laptops or computers at home
this became relevant because everything
was was onlineed um and um most of them
actually work well while they're
studying uh I also work at esqua
deidades which is essentially a liberal
arts college I work in a communication
program so uh my students uh often want
to be journalists or or PR people um
it's not really uh the math and and
computer science crowd so that poses
some challenges lack of resources
Financial Resources most importantly
there are some uh language barriers
arithmophobia and technophobia um to to
lesser lesser degree as well and um why
why care about this uh we shouldn't
exclude people uh based own language or
or financial resource
situation um and I also think it
benefits Society in general if
journalists are actually statistically
literate uh that's that's for the better
good um we can discuss whether it
matters for PR people
um we um um we have a a a host of
English Majors who are fresh out of work
because of chat GPT
if we give them some some data science
uh they have some marketable skills we
can help them out but mostly and and
foremost uh this diversity enriches our
community um they bring in perspectives
and they bring in uh new inspiration and
and that's good for for us so the
resource situation was very easily
solved when uh positive Cloud uh became
available there's a free version which I
use with my students and it runs on on
everything um what you see here is um an
18-year-old um One Laptop per child
computer they were distributed by the
government um almost two decades ago uh
now the only use they have is to browse
the internet and that is essentially all
you need for for posit cloud and I have
another example here um this is me
checking in on a training job while I'm
out to dinner
on my cell phone not recommended but it
it does actually work if uh if it's
absolutely if it's absolutely needed um
and then I want to talk a little bit
about language barriers um in R itself
take a look at this
code this is what our code might look
like if you see it for the first time
and your first language is not English
uh this is essentially a trivial data
analysis from the documentation of
deer um but think about that for a
moment if you don't have semantic access
to the function names uh then you know
it's going to be a little more it's
going to be a little more difficult this
is not something that I think we can
solve by by forking R and rewriting all
the functions but it Bears um thinking
about it we should keep it in mind that
there is going to be a steeper learning
curve for for this population you know
for any programming language in fact
because they're they're all going to be
english-based um there's interface uh
issues um that's easier to solve and in
fact it has been solved for French uh
not for my use case but I'm sure uh you
know that's going to be updated shortly
um easy enough to fix and it does uh it
does help but but the most important
um uh I think the most important one is
to have teaching materials in the
language of the students um and here I
am trying to make a contribution by um
publishing everything that I use and and
create it freely available online uh and
there are more people in the community
who who do this um so there is a growing
uh not enough but there is a growing
body of of teaching materials that we
can
um work on so arithmophobia the fear of
numbers I have um sort of three areas
where I've been trying to to work on
that the first is um
curriculum um this is um sort of a
standard setup for uh intro to
stats um and this is how I reshuffled it
for for my purposes I'm not saying this
is the only way to do it but I move
certain things around hopefully that
makes it easier for you know for the
student to to get into this um and I'm
going to go through the top two here the
first one is hypothesis testing um with
Carl popper um and I bring him up to
week three for for two reasons first of
all I I can tell my students these are
you know Humanity students and and Carl
poer is a philosopher he's one of your
lot uh yet he is he's fundamental to
everything we do in empirical science um
and the other reason is there's no
there's no coding homework in week three
um and that reduces the likelihood that
the students drop the class you know
they've just been exposed to what you
saw and um they need they need a little
break so so that's that's the other
reason um and then I I've moved the the
kis Square analysis up um it requires
very little data
to u to get going show up with four
numbers um and and you're essentially
done um visualization is is easy not not
beautiful but it is easy to to get going
and it's a very intuitive uh imbalance
that that we're analyzing and it doesn't
have a lot of requirements um if any of
you have done a te test lately you will
remember that there are up to seven
assumptions attached to that here there
there are very very very few um and you
know rmob there's only four numbers you
have to deal with here you get a result
so um the other thing I I like to do is
use relevant data what you see here is a
uh data that gets published by the
government on um income among other
things um and with you know very little
analysis you get um here there's a
gender gap in Pay um the the mean salary
is actually quite low ridiculously low
uh and there's a huge standard deviation
so you have a lot of income disparity
with very little analysis you you you uh
describe Argentine society and I think
this is interesting um more interesting
than than penguins and empty cars uh for
for this population because it speaks to
issues that matter to to us in the
society where we live and and work and
and study so so I think I think this is
um interesting um I'm if anyone is
interested in uh live coding and Shen
freuder as a pedagogical device
um I do live code a lot um to demystify
the process you know it's a lot of of
trial and error and it's it's very
iterative and and it takes forever um
that's something that that should be
known um and Shard and freuder the way I
I used that as a pedagogical tool is to
take some bad research some bad data
analysis and ask my students to to have
at it and and that's they do that with
with gusto um and it it it works um for
me it's worked very well um because it's
sort of you can learn from the errors of
others before you learn and have the
confidence to learn from your own errors
so um from that point of view it's it's
useful and I I want to take a moment to
think about what it is is that we teach
when we teach data science you've seen
this surely before this V diagram was
omnipresent in in data science
presentations at the beginning when we
sort of had to justify um ourselves um
and um I feel we've sort of used it up
but anyways so um as um as a
teacher I think we're doing this I think
we're doing this to these two parts and
I really think that it is the student
who is the domain expert so we we create
a data science team here um providing
the the different components um on on
either side and I want to show two
examples um the first one is Matia Salto
he studies Billboards in the in the
subway system in the capital city um and
it's interested in warm and cold colors
and how they relate to the product
that's being
advertised um when you pry open an an
image you get a bunch of color
codes um and then he took those and
created color
profiles for the different images for
the different products that he was
studying here you know you have headache
drugs um there's candy in the middle and
cell phone service uh on the right there
um and then he created a classifier
model using the colors as predictors
essentially which I thought was was very
clever and I don't know anything about
color as you can tell from from my slide
deck uh so in in this case you know it
really is the student who brought that
expertise uh to uh to the four and we
were able to do this know I I can help
with code and I can help with me
methods um and then there's Camila
Ramirez um she works on animated shorts
um small films that uh have no dialogue
so it's all visual language and she's
interested in studying color as a
semiotic
resource and uh when you probably open a
movie download it from YouTube you get a
series of frames you get 20 9.3 frames
per second or something like that and
then you can do the same thing you can
do an a colar analysis on each frame and
now you have a color timeline for the
movie and when I saw this I said you
know I I don't know what's going on in
this movie but I know when it's going on
because there's a timeline along the
x-axis um and so this is you know
quantitative
semiotics I thought it was absolutely
brilliant again the student is the
expert here I've provided some method
and some code U but this is really uh
the work of a domain expert um that uh
in collaboration so so I think I don't
think we should be using this this
diagram anymore um and uh I think I'm
going to skip to my conclusions now um
uh if you teach data science uh you
should try to be relevant and be real
and be there and if you don't teach data
science you should keep supporting those
of us who
do thank
you
thanks Alexander should I leave this um
hang on yeah Jill will be next and
she'll be yeah virtual so um we do have
a minute or two for questions if anyone
does have one you could just uh raise
your hand at this point if you don't
have slid
up I I have one I was thinking um like
the the code is in English like you were
saying and it's hard to get get that
like translated and still work right uh
is there anything that you do to try to
get over that barrier like what what are
the tools that people use to help people
understand if English is in their first
language well so there's there's two
well first of all the the the function
names are arbitrary but they haven't
been assigned randomly I mean they have
been assigned by a programmer for you
know to be able to retrieve the
information that's encoded in the in the
function I mean there's a reason we name
functions
um and as I said um and I I sort of want
to stick to that I don't think we should
try and overcome this because then you
would sort of Disconnect a linguistic uh
minority from the from the general
community and that's you know that's
division that's not
diversity um and it would be
counterproductive in in a you know in a
in a in a long you know in ways that are
too many to to sort of list so it is
more about um if you write your own
function write it in any language you
want if you use somebody else's
functions you you're going to have to
learn enough English to be able to read
it um so it's just you know be aware
that this is deeper learning curve I I
think that's the you know that's my
answer to to that problem and be
sensitive to it cool any other questions
real quick yeah she's got one yep hi
thank you for my question is what can we
as contributors to the r univers dos our
doation that we post that make things
easier so the question was for the
virtual audience um what can we in our
universe do to kind of help um make it
easier for people who don't speak
English as a first language and whatnot
yeah I think publishing uh teaching
materials online um and uh I guess my we
we need to do a better job marketing
them so that other people uh get a hold
of them and and can can use them um you
know I would love to have a curated
collection of uh textbooks in my case
textbook in in Spanish for for
statistics uh I haven't found that I
found bits and pieces to uh you know
that are that are useful um so U but but
I think that's it you have to put your
stuff online and make sure it's I guess
you have to make sure it's LIC Ed
correctly with a uh freefor all license
what it's share or like um creative
comments I think is the most useful
license um uh so that other people can
use it um and and contact people uh and
collaborate I think that's uh you know I
think we're also doing that uh but we
could do more of it great thank you so
much Alexander absolutely thank
you